[Music]
the Mandalorian is being made into a
feature film and there's more
information about Avatar 3 and four and
a sequel to The Passion of the Christ
this and much more awaits you right now
in this week's Koch Che
news is Mando set to appear on the big
screen soon well at least according to
Hollywood Insider Jeff Snyder who spread
these rumors in his podcast the
Mandalorian is still regarded as one of
the most popular series in the Star Wars
universe and continues to throw viewers
the series currently comprises three
seasons and a fourth one was also
planned according to John favro the
script has already been written but
things could change as Jeff Snyder
revealed in his podcast the hot mik the
fourth season is to be replaced by a
movie Snider even anticipates that the
Mandalorian movie could be released
before Star Wars 10 which is currently
scheduled for
2026 however these rumors should be
taken with a grain of salt after all
Dave filon is currently working on his
own star St Wars movie which is supposed
to bring together and conclude all the
previous story lines of the movers an
impromptu Mandalorian movie could really
disrupt these plans especially since a
sequel to Ahsoka is also on the pipeline
things are getting a little confusing
anyway in addition to Star Wars 10
filoni's movie and the possible
Mandalorian movie other movies are also
being planned Indiana Jones 5 director
James Mangold is working on a Jedi
origin story with Dawn of the Jedi the
or four director Tao ITI wants to make a
particularly humorous Star Wars movie
and Deadpool 3 director Shawn Levy will
also be realizing his own idea of Star
Wars not to mention the upcoming series
Skeleton Crew the Acolyte and the second
season of Andor so there's lots going on
when it comes to Star Wars we are
excited to see what direction the movies
and series will take after all day filon
is now primarily responsible for the
creative development of the entire
franchise we hope this will help keep
the complex universe together May the
force be with him
news from Pandora James Cameron reveals
details about the state of production
and the storylines of his upcoming
Avatar sequels at the end of 2022 the
director once again demonstrated the
potential of his science fiction film
series with Avatar the way of water the
result worldwide box office takings of
over $2.3 billion Parts three four and
five are now scheduled for release in
2025 2029 and 2031 Cameron told People
magazine that Avatar 3 is mostly
finished and that it is already possible
to watch complete scenes in part three
we are introduced to the ash people who
are described as an aggressive Clan
among the na'vi and are said to be
anything but peaceloving the director
also confirmed that Kate Winslet will
return in her role as ronal the Met
cayena clan leader became a fan favorite
in avatar The Way of water and the
character is set to play a much bigger
role in the series in order to better
immerse herself in the character Winslet
went into the care of a real Shaman who
taught her various purification rituals
in Avatar 4 however there will be a time
Jump of several years according to
Cameron it is thus necessary to shoot
scenes with younger actors now the
remaining scenes with the older actors
will be shot after Avatar 3 in other
words in 2026 at the
earliest the game continues after sawx
turned out to be a huge success winning
over fans and critics alike Lionsgate
has now given the green light for
another installment of the popular
horror franchise after sawx director
Kevin gudder already expressed interest
in another part during an interview with
film starts Lionsgate has now confirmed
the rumors via Instagram saw 11 will be
coming as early as next year a published
poster even reveals when the new part
will make its way into movie theaters
things are already set to continue on
September 27th 2024 nothing has known
about the plot and a possible return of
Tobin Bell as John Kramer in Saw 11 yet
but we'll keep you up to date as
always Supergirl drama new rumor
suggests that Sasha kayi will no longer
be featured as Supergirl in the upcoming
DCU according to Industry Insider Daniel
rpk DC is currently looking for a new
supergirl actress for James gun's
Superman Legacy most recently Superman's
female cousin was played by Sasha Cay
who first took on the role in The Flash
although there has been no official
confirmation of the rumor so far the
news has caused a stir a fans some of
them expressed their anger via social
media While others stressed that they
should wait for confirmation should
Supergirl really be recast the choice
would have to fall on an actress who is
available to the DCU for a longer period
of time because of her age we will have
to wait and see how the situation
unfolds and whether Warner and Sasha
Kaya will issue a statement on the
rumors in the near
future he's back 20 years after Mel
Gibson's box office Hit The Passion of
the Christ Resurrection part one is now
to be made The Passion of the Christ is
probably one of the most controversial
movies of recent decades the sanguinary
Reconstruction of Jesus's passion in
particular caused a lot of heated
discussion with worldwide box office
takings of over 612 million the film was
extremely successful despite all the
criticism and a sequel was announced in
2016 Now The Passion of the Christ
Resurrection part 1 is about to be
realized according to the cinema holic
filming is set to begin next year and
will take place partly in Rome and
Mexico according to initial information
the eagerly awaited sequel will be set
in the days between Jesus's crucifixion
and his resurrection and will focus on
his descent into hell director Mel
Gibson himself described one script as
an acid trip Gibson also seems to be
pursuing some ambitious plans as the
sequel is to be made in two or three
parts sound of Freedom actor Jim kisel
will once again portray Jesus and Monica
beluchi might also return as Mary
Magdalene although there is no official
release date yet the film is expected to
Premiere during
2025 and the next anime liveaction
adaptation from Netflix is just around
the corner this time it's based on the
cult series my hero Academia however it
is not clear yet whether it will be made
into a movie or a series the development
of the project has already been under
discussion for a year however producer
and screenwriter Joby Harold has now
confirmed in an interview with k that
production has begun with the
participation of the author of the
original Masterpiece Koh Hiroshi the
director is shinuk Sato who already has
some experience with live-action
adaptations of Manga and Anime the
cinema photography is being handled by
Don burgus a Hollywood veteran who has
already directed plenty of Blockbusters
including Spider-Man Forest Gump and
Aquaman the manga series and anime
series my hero Academia revolves around
the aspiring student isuku who ATT
attends a school and a world full of
superheroes that is supposed to make him
a hero as well the successful franchise
has already resulted in three movies my
hero Academia two Heroes Heroes rising
and World Heroes Mission the new my hero
Academia liveaction adaptation joins the
list of numerous Netflix projects of
this kind such as Cowboy bbop one piece
and the recently confirmed Naruto
adaptation Dwayne Johnson is to Star as
MMA Legend Mark Kerr in the new drama
the mashing machine from film company
a24 it is said to be the most profound
role the action star has ever taken on
the movie is about the very rough period
of the UFC in 2000 when Kerr was at the
peak of his career the story highlights
his personal battle with substance abuse
and his own experiences with Victory
love and friendship the moving story
inspired an HBO documentary of the same
name back in 2003 the director of the
smashing machine will be Benny safy he
has previously directed movies together
with his brother John most recently the
Netflix hit uncut gems with Adam Sandler
the MMA movie will be his debut as a
solo director we can't wait to see
whether he can bring out a convincing
performance from the charismatic but so
far rather one-dimensional Dwayne
Johnson as a character
actor there was a lot going on on our
Channel this week in addition to
trailers for Dune 2 and Kung Fu Panda 4
we also uploaded movie previews for
Superman Legacy as well as the electric
State the new movie from the aveng
director leave a like and tell us your
opinion are you looking forward to the
new Star Wars projects and do you think
Dwayne Johnson is capable of playing a
serious role we're definitely looking
forward to reading your
[Music]
comments